hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled navigating the sars2
pandemic at riverview health
this webinar is part of the 2021
microbiology virtual week and i am susie
valdez of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinths and sponsored by luminix for
more information about luminix go to
www.luminexcorp.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the far right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker ronald
rettenhauer an area coordinator of
microbiology hazmat and disaster
preparedness for riverview health in
noblesville indiana for a complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen ronald welcome you
may now begin
hello my name is ron rittenhauer and i'm
with riverview health in noblesville
indiana
we are a 156 bed full service hospital
this facility is located
north of indianapolis about 45 minutes
from downtown indianapolis
we also have a 16 bed hospital in
westfield indiana approximately seven
miles to our west
and then we also have three freestanding
er agent cares as well as
over two dozen primary immediate
specialty care locations here in
hamilton county
our laboratory is a full service
laboratory
we include micro molecular diagnostics
cytology and histology
one of the things we're really proud of
here is just over 97
of our
test requests from our physicians and
all of our client facilities are
performed here in house
and we provide reference laboratory
services for three hospitals
as well as 14 long-term care facilities
so prior to the pandemic we had four
different molecular platforms that we
had employed in our laboratory
we had the cepheid gene expert
on that platform we run mrsa
surveillance
c-difficile
group b strep
as well as a genetic mutation
test for factor two and five
coagulopathies
we also brought in the panther
in 2013
in the panther we have a pretty robust
menu we run gonorrhea chlamydia
mycoplasma genitalium
trichomonas vaginalis
hpv
hpv genotyping and a vaginitis panel
a couple years after that we were able
to bring in the abbott id nows as a
quick molecular screen for flu a and b
rsv and group a strep
and then in 2016 we were fortunate
enough to bring in uh the verigene
platform
on the varagine
platform we run the gram negative and
gram positive blood culture panels as
well as the respiratory flex panel and
the entire
pathogens panel
the benefits that we saw in bringing the
vera gene in
were
a lot towards our antimicrobial
stewardship program
so the blood culture panels
compared to conventional culture allow
us to do directed treatment 28 to 48
hours faster
which is much better for patient
outcomes
the respiratory flex panel
provides us a very robust screening tool
for respiratory pathogens
it provided us a backup for our rapid
flu and rrsp testing
and we had a large amount of border tele
testing
that was coming from peds practices that
we were having to send out
so we were able to bring in
all of these assays under this one
platform and and do quite a bit as well
as with the entire panel and improving
the screening tool we had over
conventional culture
life before the pandemic
in my department we had two to three
ftes on day shift
just depending on the day of the week
and the volume
on the vera gene uh those volumes
included a very steady amount of blood
culture and enteric panels and then of
course the respiratory panel volume
[Music]
varied depending on the season so
fall and winter time we would see a
significant increase in that volume
but that was easily handled in the daily
workflow
at the bottom of the slide you can see
the verizon workflow for those of you
that aren't familiar with platform
it's a very effective tool for a
facility our size
we started off with
just one of the processors and reader
we're now up to three
but you can see on the bottom there it's
a
pretty simple just adding your sample
the different components and letting the
instrument
do the processing and then at the very
last step reading the panels for you
so
as the pandemic started
there weren't very many
assays available to
any facilities
so
all of our testing was either having to
be sent to a state laboratory
or when some of the large commercial
reference laboratories started offering
it
there was places that we could send
covered pcr testing
so initially before we had any
capabilities
we use the verigene
respiratory flex panel as a rule out
test
so in fact the state
lab in order to send a specimen you had
to get authorization
so we would perform the test in-house
with the respiratory flex panel
if no targets were found
and we had a symptomatic patient then we
could get approval to send that specimen
to the state for testing
we did have
two platforms that
were initially available for testing
they were the gene expert and the id now
but because of
the amount of
facilities that use those platforms
it was next to impossible to get a
sufficient inventory to really do any
significant
testing
therefore we went with purchase of an
aries platform
and we started with the aries in doing a
lab develop test
once the lab developed test was fully
implemented
then the eua became available so
we
were going to transition straight to the
eua but because of allocation issues
then
for quite some time we ran both ldt and
eua
four covert on the aries
and the usage was just based on what
product was available that week how much
we could get
so until the large scale production of
the eua
we mixed both ldt and eua in the same
day sometimes
now we are exclusively on the eua assay
what the aries really allowed for us to
do was prioritize patients in our
facility so
we
focused on patients in our er
we focused on getting our surgeries
elective surgeries back operational so
we were able to screen those patients
in-house the day before testing
i'm sorry the day before their surgery
any employees that were suspected of
being infected we were able to run those
and get those results out the same day
for employee health
and then
we've supported
three to four of our local fire
departments in testing
the first responders from those
departments
because of the testing that we were
doing
the indiana department of health reached
out to us
to join a network that they were
creating to help increase the
capacity of testing within the state
so initially they asked nine
laboratories across indiana
to join this network and with that
we were able to get
a higher increase in the allocations of
various reagents
and since we already had a panther
in-house
we were able to bring in
sars testing on the panther as well
as part of that partnership we also
obtained the second aries instrument
that we put into place
so as the volumes continue to increase
we did have a problem with the panther
because
the t-can tips that are used on the
panther
became very hard to get and those were
on allocation so even if i could get
panther
actima reagents i might not have the
tips to be able to run the instrument
so therefore working with the state
department of health or the department
of health
we ended up adding two luminex magpix
instruments
as well as a bmru emag to do the
extractions and then two thermocyclers
as the pandemic raged on and we were
doing all this testing i was able to add
two ftes to the department so we added
an additional fte to day shift
and then one to second shift and we had
not had
anyone but generalist on our second
shift
so we added a molecular specialist onto
our second shift just to keep
the panther instrument flowing and then
run any of those
that we're going to run on the aries
bringing those in at night
the magpix and the panther combination
really allowed us to increase our
capacity
in a major way and reallocate
um the use of the instrumentation so
we run a lot of stuff on the panther so
bringing the magpix in allowed us to
take some of the burden off of that so
we could continue to perform some other
testing
in addition
when we got both of those online the
state started sending specimens
from outside our network to us to run
and a lot of those tests that were being
collected within the county were
actually being ran out of state
because the capacity issues
all around the area so there were a lot
of tests going i believe out to
wisconsin that we were able to keep in
state within the county
and then of course running those other
larger
high throughput platforms allowed us to
really focus more on
the aries as using it for our direct
admits again more pre-surgical screening
employee screening and our first
responders
pandemic stability stabilization we did
have a
time where things were starting to
[Music]
decrease pretty significantly in volumes
as i record this
the last two weeks we have been back at
record volumes so
slide is
chronologically good but um we are
very busy again and back to
um high pandemic levels but
use of these platforms really
uh was helpful when the volumes start to
decrease
so we changed our focus
from doing all the testing that had been
coming in
because it was a much lower volume we
started offering direct consumer testing
for individuals that needed travel
testing
so they could pay upfront
schedule an appointment
and because of the way the aries
platform works we were able to get these
results out same day for these folks
and that's really important because of
the time frames that some of the
countries were requiring
most of them are 72 hours but it kind of
depends on
what connecting flights you have some
people were having to get results back
the same day so that they could make
their flights
it's been a very popular program but it
did have some
some drawbacks
each destination has very specific
requirements so the type of test used
we had to make sure a lot of them
require real-time pcr
the collection methods you know was it
nasopharyngeal
nasal oropharyngeal and what
and then eventually we had to add a qr
code to our reports um
just to satisfy specific requirements
for some countries
kind of
one of the odd things is that
we've sent people with travel testings
all over the globe
and not had any issues with the
exception of hawaii
and hawaii will not accept our results
because we're not
an approved lab on their site
but i just thought that was interesting
because we've been approved by all these
other countries except for a state in
our own
our own country
so moving on from the pandemic hopefully
the surge we're in right now will will
subside and we can start getting back to
normal
but moving on from the pandemic
having these different platforms in
place
or wanting to to really be able to
expand what we're offering
so on the aries i want to increase test
offerings
one thing for certain that i want to add
from there
would be the hsv one and two
we want to increase our panther test
offerings
hiv quantitative as well as hcv and hbv
and then
hope to upgrade our vera gene to the
verite fair gene 2 platform
that should be a pretty exciting
offering and
when that comes out my understanding is
there'll be a flex panel for the
enterics as well
so one of my
jobs at the hospital besides
microbiology is emergency management and
we always look at
any exercises or responses lessons
learned
so from our response
to this covert pandemic
some of the things we've really learned
are flexibility in the laboratory
prior to the pandemic
in a lot of cases especially molecular
wise
we really just tried to minimize the
number of platforms that we were using
so that you know we could control cost
and
not have
too many different
instruments that we had to manage and
maintain
but
with the way the supply chain broke down
during the pandemic
we learned we really need to be more
flexible and not rely on a single
platform or vendor
so we want to be able to implement
testing across multiple platforms so if
you've got two to three different
platforms that you can
alternate on depending on the
available resources
then you can continue to
offer those services
even when the supply chain breaks down
on you
so one thing you really need to do with
that is make sure you validate multiple
specimen types and collection devices
across those platforms
as well as look at a way to prioritize
testing on one platform over the other
the other big thing is um and
you know we're a relatively small
laboratory
and i've always steered away from doing
ldt's or lab developed tests
but
use of the ldt
really provided a lot of flexibility and
we were able to adapt quickly
luminex did a great job in helping
support and helping to teach and and
give me understanding
of what i needed to do as far as
validation for an ldt
and
it it just made a huge difference and it
got us up testing much quicker than
waiting
for the euas to be available
one of the major things though um
that is still a challenge is storage
space
so bringing on multiple platforms and
having issues with
being able to obtain viral transport
media being able to attain pipette tips
we had to purchase
as much of
each of those type of items as we could
when they were available
so i actually had to
take a a mechanical room that we have
down the hall from the laboratory and
change that into a store room to be able
to have
enough space
lastly you want to have a transition
plan
and this can be as simple as my priority
samples go on this
instrument by backup samples or the ones
that don't require as much
of a short turnaround time they can go
on this platform
and then if
reagents aren't available for platform
one or two or three
how do you transition between each of
those
so
this table shows our current platforms
and the assays that we have
in-house right now as our current asset
is and then it also shows potential
assays that we could bring on board
so in working on transition plan
you want to look at
what all options do i have
in my laboratory currently that i could
quickly transition
from using one platform and going to
another
it's not always easy to keep reagents on
board for everything but if you at least
have
one alternate platform to move to that
will allow you
to continue providing that best
even when you have a supply chain issue
all right so
another transition
to think about is just when you go from
high volume to low volume
so as you can see the panther is one of
our primary high volume instruments
when the volume decreases we can focus
more on
on the aries which is an easier
and cheaper platform to run
and then as
volumes go back up we transition back
over to the panther which is what we're
seeing majorly right now with this
uptick in the
[Music]
the surge that we're having in indiana
right now
and with that
that's the information i have to provide
if you have any questions i'll be happy
to answer those questions for you
okay great
thank you so much rowan for your
informative presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
let's get started
our first question i have here ron what
type of quality assurance do you perform
between platforms
so we purchased the
cap
quality cross check
survey comes out twice a year has three
challenges
and then you can perform it between all
platforms but of course you could
use your own samples just between
different platforms
thank you and then the next one i have
here
what has been the biggest challenge with
testing during the pandemic
i would say without a doubt just
dealing with supplies
making sure that we have enough
of the different reagents to run the
different platforms but
probably more importantly than that even
as all the consumables that go along
with it
been a lot of issue with plastics over
the last year and a half
and of course most of the components for
consumables and the cartridges are
plastic so
simply just trying to keep ahead finding
different vendors to go through
and
really changing the way that i used to
order
so i used to order a case now i may be
ordering 10 20 cases at a
and a little less concern about
expiration dates because we go through
things so quickly
all right thank you so much ron and
thank you again for your time today and
your important research uh before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us and for their interesting
questions i'd also like to thank our
sponsor luminex for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until september 9th of
2023
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to email that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event ron again thank you so much
and until next time goodbye